До Жованки веде одна
єдина вулиця. Вона продірявлена
вибоїнами від снарядів. До того ж,
у повітрі витає страх, що будь-якої миті
можна потрапити під обстріл
сепаратистських снайперів.
Оті пагорби - це вже територія,
контрольована сепаратистами.
Без допомоги ззовні півтори сотні
мешканців Жованки, переважно похилого віку,
не могли б звести кінці з кінцями.
Громадського транспорту
тут більше немає - ось уже три роки,
відколи почалася війна. До найближчого
магазину треба йти пішки кілька годин.
Добровольці дбають, щоб
гуманітарна допомога знаходила тих,
кому вона найбільше потрібна.
"Селище закрите. Виїхати звідси можливості нема.
Транспорт не їздить.
Ви бачите, яка велика кількість людей
похилого віку, які не в стані кудись доїхати.
Люди тут виживають.
Здебільшого живуть за рахунок натурального господарства".
Село відрізане від світу -
Люди виживають лише за рахунок
небагатого врожаю своїх городів.
Каті - 27 років.
Вона мати-одиначка. Її будинок розташований
на околицях села -
майже на лінії фронту. Друзів
у її дітей немає.
Інші сім’ї з дітьми вже давно виїхали.
Щодня вже майже два тижні
б’ють і б’ють без перерв.
Раніше було страшно. А зараз
вже якось звикли.
Спершу сім’я ховалася від обстрілів
у погребі. Але коли й той
стали обстрілювати, діти і мама
залишаються просто в спальні.
Це найбільш віддалена кімната, куди з
найменшою вірогідністю щось потрапить.
З цього боку - наш рідний будинок
нас захищає. А з того -
рідко коли щось падає.
І дерева захищають. У цю хату
якось  - тьху-тьху - ще ні разу
не влучили.
70 метрів. Вони вже на
наступній вулиці. Наступна вулиця -
третя - це вже сепаратистів.
З пагорбів стріляють снайпери сепаратистів,
розповідають селяни.
Катя показує, що залишилося
від її погребу.
Якби було моє щось, рідне, я би поїхала.
А на пташині права я не поїду.
Я вже двічі їздила.
Прощаємося з Катею і вирушаємо
в бік лінії фронту. Повсюди одні
лише руїни. Та - окопи.
Більшість з них недостатньо глибокі,
аби стояти в них. Два українські солдати
несуть тут службу - батько та син.
"Стріляють на нашій ділянці, вночі переважно стріляють,
вдень спокійніше, а взагалі-то стріляють".
У цю пору року тут рано стає темно.
З настанням сутінків залишатися тут надто небезпечно -
знімальна група мусить залишити село.
Лише за кілька кілометрів звідси -
зовсім інший світ:
контрольно-пропускний пункт у Майорському.
Тут місцеві можуть переходити
на інший бік - з контрольованої урядом території у підконтрольну сепаратистам.
Щодня близько 10 тисяч
людей стоять тут у чергах.
У мене батько помер, от я їздив батька хоронив.
За пенсією.
З Горлівки в Артемівськ.
Дуже погана організація.
Особливо з того боку - жахливо!
Але безпечним цей пункт
не назвеш. Останніми місяцями
тут не раз стріляли. Такі КПП
з’явилися як тимчасове явище,
але реальність зробила їх
невід’ємною частиною
сьогодення на Донбасі -
ось уже понад три роки.